what's an assault rifle uh like
one of them really large guns let me ask
you are you aware of what
the differentiation is between automatic
and semi-automatic no
people either have the right to protect
themselves or they don't and there is no
data to say that stripping people have
the right to self-protection would make
us safer
so for this week's installment i've
changed my mind we decided to revisit
the very topical issue of gun control in
the second amendment
matter of fact we returned to ut dallas
where we conducted our last segment on
this topic to see if anything had
changed
[Music]
now we're going to get to the two fully
unedited interviews in a second that's
the whole purpose of change my mind to
see what real conversations in real time
uh how they unfold but two things that
really struck me first number one
in a day full of conversations it seemed
that none of the even highly educated
students knew
anything about basic proper firearm
classifications or terminology
well i know fully automatic is the one
that is like restricted or an assault
rifle like what
why does someone need that assault rifle
or uh you know an automatic
machine gunner ars the same assault
rifle that was used in the recent
florida shooting
and two everyone wanted to talk about
florida obviously but shockingly not a
single student
not one had ever heard of the far deadly
or sutherland springs shooting
which took place in their own backyard
remember the sutherland spring shooting
that was right here in texas
you know what happened there right does
the name stephen williford mean anything
to you no
do you remember the sutherland springs
shooting
does the name stephen williford mean
anything to you
okay you remember the sutherland springs
i've heard of it
just now with the other girl from me
yeah for me absolutely terrifying how
could they not know of a shooting
with 26 deaths another 20 injured which
occurred only four hours away in which
the shooter was stopped by an nra
certified instructor with an ar15 a
national hero mind you stephen williford
but i repeat myself on with the
conversations okay so what was your name
again muad
mawad yes right um
i've asserted my position i think pretty
hopefully pretty clearly
um changed my mind so what do you think
about australia
1996. what about australia when they uh
buy back yeah i think it's terrible
really
why i think i think a gun ban stripping
citizens of the right to protect
themselves i think that's an immoral act
but i mean what if you look at the
statistics behind that the decline of
you know shootings deaths by gun it's
probably much less than we have per day
here
know what no it didn't it didn't have a
statistical effect on uh on violent
crime or even gun crime
matter of fact it came about the online
articles that
that say yeah otherwise we've written
plenty of them as well over to eladora
with kiter.com
and uh something more fascinating
there's an overall decrease in violent
crime there's an overall decrease often
in gun crime um and in new zealand where
they didn't have a mandatory buyback
you saw the same kind of overall trends
uh
so yeah i think it's i think it's
horrible um i think we both admit
it's a ban okay right yeah yeah so it
was considered a buyback which has been
proposed here
it was a mandatory buyback that's a gun
ban so i guess my question to you would
be
um would you like to do that in the
united states
i would love to to be honest personally
just ban guns honestly like what i mean
i understand there's
it's fun shooting a gun i've been to a
gun range before
there's a nice adrenaline feeling when
you're shooting at a target like you
know and it's just satisfying when you
hit the middle of the target it's
just like any other sport shirt per se
but um i feel like
we would gain so much more as a country
in the long run if you're thinking of a
bigger picture like
less possibilities of psychos killing
people like in las vegas
or just most recently where 17 people
died in a school right
i mean honestly like if i were to give
up my
my favorite hobby playing soccer if that
meant that
hundreds of people wouldn't die i would
gladly do it any day because i love my
country that much
great what do you believe the second
amendment is about
the right to bear on the right to bear
arms to protect yourself and
that's pretty much what i know i'm
really ignorant on this if i'm honest
oh really oh okay okay well listen i
appreciate you sitting down um
i don't mean to be contentious but you
mentioned it as a hobby
so um the first amendment okay right the
right to freedom of speech
do you believe that's absolute do you
believe that you should have the right
to speak freely without
having that be infringed upon by the
government okay and why do you believe
that
uh because just being able to express
your beliefs uh publicly and having that
as
you know a freedom is is essential to
the development of democracy in a
country
but where do you get that from who in
what sense
like what do you mean well where do you
get the the right to the freedom of
speech you said you believe that that is
fundamental you believe that's very
important to a democracy or to like a
constitutional republic
i just i just gave you a hint there in
that uh constitution
yeah yeah okay so so you're right
because you know the freedom of speech
is not
absolute it doesn't exist across many
other countries including free countries
including australia by the way you don't
have the right to free speech in
australia okay
so you believe the right to freedom of
speech is absolute because of the
constitution the first amendment
amendment number two is what the right
to bear arms
okay so did the australians amend their
whatever constitution they have when
they had that buyback
i can't speak to the specifics of all
elements of the australian constitution
okay
now i do know again that uh where i come
from for example in canada you can be
jailed for speech that's offensive or
you can be fined
so we decided to do things differently
from many places in europe
and certainly australia as it relates to
freedom of speech as well as the second
amendment
but i think it's important you just said
you believe freedom of speech is
absolute
why because you accept the premise that
these rights
as recognized by the constitution are
fundamental human rights
so when it comes to the life and of our
citizens yes
do you not believe that we have let's
say any let's like what if
just you know in general like does when
it comes to protecting the lives of
citizens and immigrants and anyone who
lives in america when it comes to that
do you believe that
there should be some flexibility in our
constitution
to protect our people so first off a
couple of
couple of key issues there right you
would have to
uh open it wide and now also nothing is
absolute so your freedom of speech is an
absolute so you would have to be
comfortable with that
secondly it's based on this premise that
we would save lives by
removing the second amendment which i
don't agree with
but let's go with with number one um do
you see
what a problem that is if you just say
well let's hold on a second because we
think we can be safer
let's give up this fundamental right to
protection uh
as recognized in the second amendment
can we acknowledge or maybe find common
ground there that
that'd be a real problem because it's
the same constitution that affords
you and i the right to do what we're
doing right now i mean i understand that
wholeheartedly but if we're thinking of
the bigger picture here where
like i mean i've seen things on social
media where people believe that teachers
should have guns and i mean so do you
just
as a human being do you think that the
amount of shootings that we have
every day in our country would decrease
if we had a buyback
like just thinking you know basic common
sense okay so we've now
i want to make sure that we're clear
here we've hopscotched past the idea of
human rights
it seems like that's not an area you're
super comfortable with because now
you're talking about stripping someone
of their fundamental right to
self-protection is having a gun if it
saves someone else's life
i mean why not why not i mean why not
you know like
take that step as a country take that
step as a country yes
removing someone's right to protect
themselves protect themselves from what
so explain to me since so the second
amendment so you all right um
no no you're gonna do your thing okay so
yeah second amendment you are do you
want me to explain what it is no yeah
sure so the second amendment was
designed to allow citizens to protect
themselves
uh cells both from internal and external
threats that means the right to protect
obviously
in their home property but mainly to
protect themselves from a tyrannical
government
because they fled a trinical government
they fought them off right these were
basically unorganized uh militias
who was a militia it's everyone you and
i are the militia
and the only way to ensure that there
can be a well-regulated militia meaning
a capable militia is that
all citizens have the right law-abiding
citizens
to keep and bear arms that's what it was
designed to do
you're proposing giving the government
the very fail-safe it's designed against
to protect against the tyrannical
government you're saying let's give the
government the authority
to strip people of rights
that's like a feat a feedback loop of
just a violation of human rights on a
scale that i don't think you might know
you personally do you think having the
right to free speech
is more important than having the right
to a gun no
i think you're both people we think
they're both equally important yeah so
you think like
for the development of our country it's
essential to have guns and free speech
and you think they're on the same level
in a scale
i think the right to own and keep
fighting it's more like a right
thing yes for you okay well i mean
why why is it just america that we have
tens of thousands of deaths per year
it's not i mean it is on it if you look
at statistics no we're not even
25. oh really yeah we're not even top 25
when it comes to firearm deaths we're
not even
we are the most armed populist but we're
not even the top country for mass
shootings matter of fact we're behind
norway and france
even though more people here have guns i
don't know i think we've
never heard of these statistics before
honestly i don't know where you get
yours from because
all of the ones that i've seen okay show
that america is always topping that list
okay uh well let's say we're able to
show you statistics afterwards
let's assume that those are correct okay
um it still can get to the question
let's assume
let's assume none of them are correct
what gives
you the right or what gives anyone here
the right
to strip someone of their ability to
protect themselves
so why don't we dissect that a little
what are we protecting ourselves from i
know you mentioned it from
internal and external threats so what
are those threats
tyrannical government okay yeah okay and
then of course the ability to protect
yourself from anyone who wants to do you
harm from evil people who are willing to
commit
uh harm i mean i don't i don't know why
that
that should you know have anything to do
with being able to own an assault rifle
assault rifle or you know an automatic
machine gun or anything like that
okay first off a couple things there um
what do you um
what's an assault rifle uh like
one of them really large guns
okay um yeah there's a lot to unpack
there
no no it's not i'm just going to
automatically yeah i know i mean
you mentioned a few things what kind of
where do you get your news from forgive
me or your sources what do you usually
read
cnn uh cnn twitter
cnn twitter and a lot of professors
probably here probably right
um everything that you have said here
and i said respectfully is incorrect
about the australia buyback the
statistics about that about
uh the second amendment now about
assault rifles and automatic weapons
none of the shootings that you've
discussed that we've discussed here
involved automatic weapons certainly not
florida these are not automatic weapons
automatic weapons are already heavily
regulated they're basically all but
unattainable for the actual
las vegas guy use yeah he's used to
semi-automatic
okay so semi-automatic and switch that
word what about that why do
people need to have this i'm sorry i
didn't know but do you wanna explain
what the difference is because
that's really important don't you think
because you you said here's something
and i
i appreciate you sitting down but you
sat down here
and you were willing to strip people of
their rights you were willing to say
listen it's time to progress as a
country which i'll get to in a second um
will cause countless more muggings
murders rapes of innocent people the
likes of which you've never
you've never even been able to
comprehend and didn't take into account
you were willing to remove the right of
those innocent civilians to protect
themselves
based on completely faulty data and
knowledge of things that simply aren't
so
there's a huge difference between an
automatic weapon that's a machine gun
and a semi-automatic weapon a
semi-automatic weapon
is every handgun pull the trigger once
it goes bang that's a semi-automatic
weapon that's most hunting rifles
that's nearly all handguns that are used
for self-defense so my point is
if if and i say this respect because a
lot of people have sat down so this is
not an insult but almost everything that
you just said is
is incorrect as a premise and you were
using that
or going up based on that knowledge um
to justify the stripping of someone's
ability to protect themselves
that is deeply so wonderful to me so i
obviously went to the extreme of just
banning guns
what if we you know improved our
regulation
or improved our our way of giving people
access to these
guns okay so we've got enough so you
would say now let's not ban
guns so i'm yeah with respect because
you know you got to please everyone
so let's just say we want to you know
just take another step do you think
we're at a
you know a good state where we're at
right now i don't i don't want to let's
just say
with what i just said would you
acknowledge now that okay
just banning guns could have some real
serious ramifications and maybe
you spoke a little too quickly on that
that might not be a good idea i'm sorry
what
so would you agree with that maybe
that's not a good idea to just ban guns
sure okay so what kind of regulations
would you like to see
and why just making it probably more
difficult for
people such as the las vegas shooter the
orlando shooter and
things like that to get access to guns
like that can and cause such
you know huge calamities to our country
um
how would you do it what do you think
i'm asking you
you're supposed to change my mind i mean
i'm just saying like we're not in a good
place where we're at right now with
regards to guns
really and from the statistics that i've
seen i don't know what which ones you
have and i
really love to look at the ones
afterwards and from what i've seen and
what i've been convinced through that
data is that
america is not in a good place with
regards to data from cnn
and twitter and professors is wrong um
uh okay so you've i'm assuming you've
probably never purchased a firearm no i
haven't okay
so if you purchase a firearm right now
they run a background check okay okay
okay you're a criminal if you're a felon
you can't get a gun okay you've
committed violent
misdemeanors you can't get a gun okay
domestic abuser you can't get a gun
legally declared mentally unfit you
can't get a gun get or own
meaning you cannot obtain you cannot
purchase it okay okay okay
so these already exist if you go to
purchase a firearm again all these
twitter
memes and stats don't believe them i
mean it doesn't mean anything it's
actual like
links to articles and very very factual
it's not just like someone
i mean i could show you what i've read
like totally just now
the point i'm making here is a lot of
this would be very easily refuted by
yourself if you'd ever purchased a
firearm you would know it's not you know
it's not true because you've gone
through the process
everyone here who's ever purchased a
firearm has gone through that process
and knows that there are strict
regulations um so
we've gone from okay maybe banning all
guns to how do we make it more difficult
for people to purchase well we already
do those things so what else would you
do why do people get guns like people
that commit these
crazy crimes like why is that still
happening you're not you're
19 times more likely to be knifed than
ever shot
i feel like you're 19 i'm just throwing
fake statistics but i feel like you're
much more likely to survive getting
stabbed than shot but the point is why
do people go out and stab i mean there's
crazy people out there
yeah well i mean what can we do as a
country in your opinion
uh stephen right stephen yes sir okay
appreciate it i just googled you
uh so um like what do you think we can
take what's our next step because we're
obviously like
this just happened like a week ago you
know
i don't believe that you think it's just
like something we should overlook
well no i think i think i think you've
overlooked a lot of data
okay i think you've overlooked empirical
evidence and i think you're you're
wanting to pass legislation through an
emotive response right now
and i appreciate where you're coming
from i think it's an empathetic place
and i would hope that you
believe where i'm coming from is an
equally empathetic place it's just a
different
solution um i believe that you want to
save more lives
okay now what you've proposed to save
more lives we've started with literally
completely stripping people of guns
which is uh very extreme i believe
that's what the left wants to do though
so i appreciate you being honest
um to okay maybe there's some
legislation there that
we do or don't know what it would look
like um
let me i've talked about this quite a
bit today our goal is to save lives
how many lives are lost you said we're
in a really bad place with guns in our
country we're all right now
are we not no are you gonna say we're
not no i don't think we're okay
listen i think every i think we are no
i'm not gonna say perfect i think a
shooting is an absolute tragedy is there
room for improvement or you think that
we're just like at a flat line
there's always room for improvement
certainly i mean when there are 39
incidents uh sorry yeah go ahead
yeah it is called freeze up a lot my
mouth might be getting blue now i've
been out here for so long
um uh sorry we were talking is a room
for improvement
um i think a man who had 39 reports two
tips to the fbi blew away a chicken
this is a guy you're talking about
florida who legally should not have been
able to purchase the firearm
okay but legally you also can't go by
crack right people find ways around the
law
yeah okay no matter what that's
inevitable that's inevitable okay that's
inevitable
now as far as we're not in a good place
in our country as it relates to
firearms that's not true overall violent
crime has been decreasing pretty
consistently over the last several
decades
i don't believe that what if i said i
don't like this i don't believe i'll
show you statistics afterwards but um
i mean you can even if you would like to
after this google violent crime
statistics they've been consistently
decreasing
and the assault weapons ban which was uh
in place between 1994 and 2004 had
no discernible effect at all on crime
okay um
how many but let's look at something
that hopefully we can just agree upon
because you're saying maybe i don't
agree on your stats
um i'll show them to you afterward and
hopefully we can find some comments on
that
let's find something that's absolute
absolutely we can agree upon
how many lives do you know are lost to
firearms each year in the united states
i know it's in the thousands yeah uh if
you include suicides it's 30-something
thousand okay
if you don't it's anywhere from 12 to
you know in the teens of thousands
depending on the course
okay so that sounds about right uh
something like that something like that
yeah
so that's let's let's take the the
highest total thirty thousand okay
okay including suicides i don't really
think it's fair to but let's do that
um what if i were to tell you that 500
000 to
at meaning a minimum to over 3 million
lives
each year saved by defensive use of
firearms the united states that's
according to the national safety council
in cdc
exponentially more lives saved through
law-abiding citizens
who own and keep firearms protecting
themselves then lost
safe from like what like what's the
criteria for that
meaning live saved meaning fact of crime
stopped from them using a firearm and by
the way that doesn't necessarily include
all statistics of
most of the time if you own a firearm
you simply show that you brandish the
firearm
and criminals will move along down the
trail but innocent lives
being saved this is according to the cdc
national safety council through
defensive use of firearms
a low end of 500 000 listed potentially
to over three million
so if we're talking about we're not in a
good place in our country more lives
with
would you at least entertain the idea
that
perhaps a way to save more innocent
lives from being lost is encouraging
uh firearm education and responsible
firearm ownership
considering the discrepancy it's
exponentially more likely that an
innocent life is
saved in the united states by a firearm
so let's say there's that that ratio of
there is that's prevented versus
that's caused by gun violence do you
think that would decrease
if there were more limitations on access
to guns
no how so well there's no evidence to
suggest that it would
i know but i'm saying like just i've got
it listen
i've got to base my opinion based on on
two things first off on the
second amendment and the constitution
and how it's recognized okay okay
because if you don't recognize that then
you don't have any rights and i don't
have any rights
it sounds to me like you enjoy some of
the rights but you don't necessarily
agree with other rights
then you have to base it on undeniable
statistical empirical data and we have
that
that's what forms my opinion not how i
feel or react based on
a horrible tragedy and and no one here
is saying that it isn't
when that occurs um but you just don't
you don't hear about those stories a lot
that makes sense i mean i don't honestly
like at the end of the day like
i feel like if you just look at it from
a common sense perspective because you
have your statistics
and apparently i have mine and and i
mean honest like when you think about it
like
he just hit your camera oops
okay oh a tolerant dude
and uh real quick i really respect what
you're doing here
thank you very much i love that despite
our extremely
you know just our extreme disagreement
in certain things i
i really respect that you're you know
you're not even hiring your voice and i
really really would like to
shake your hand but it's a fist bump
let me hold your hand and get it warmed
up no i really respect this thank you
very much no
listen and i'm not offended by anything
you said so i really appreciate it and
here's the thing
and i like you i wanted to offend me uh
that's fine
no i mean i mean i want to learn first
of all and i i've shown you where my
perspective i hope you you
understand where i'm coming from i
understand where you're coming from and
i think you're i think here's the thing
i think you're you're an empathetic
person who wants to save lives right
um and i'm just trying to tell you that
that
first off you can't save every life
right that's where i believe you're
coming from i don't i don't believe in
describing a motive you know you see
this right now at the cnn town hall
why don't you care about the lives lost
no why don't these people care about the
lives saved i mean a good example
we don't hear about remember the
sutherland spring shooting that was
right here in texas
you know what happened there right does
the name steven williford mean anything
to you no
okay this is so i have a show it's
called lotto with potter okay
stephen williford was someone i
interviewed on my show okay this is
after the
remember the southerland springs
shooting i haven't i've heard of it i
don't remember killing far more people
than the one in florida okay
uh deadly shooting in southern springs
uh just outside of uh san antonio texas
okay
um sorry southerland springs
sutherland yeah okay southerland springs
yeah sutherland
sorry i said southern first because
that's steven williford sorry okay yeah
okay so this is a very deadly shooting
that occurred at a church
this was within the last uh four months
now i'm sure you've seen all the press
obviously after florida boycott the nra
gun control now cnn town hall stephen
willoffer to some we interviewed on our
show
okay the reason i interviewed him on our
show this lowly little podcast was
because no
no one else was really even calling him
no one else really wanted to hear his
story do you know who stephen williford
is
no he's the man who stopped the active
shooter with an ar-15
okay it was a man shooting up a church
an evil man shooting up a church
and stephen williford who is a hero
shot him with an ar-15 and stopped it
so media didn't even interrupt so i
guess are you saying like everyone
should get an ar-15
no i'm not saying everyone should get an
ar-15 but what i'm saying is you say you
have your facts and you have your data
and then you acknowledge that perhaps
you're misinforming some of these issues
you mentioned cnn okay why didn't cnn
have stephen
this was a more deadly shooting carried
out against the church
here in texas stephen williford he
wasn't some kid who happened to be maybe
even a different wing of the school or
wasn't even there that day this was the
man who personally stopped
the active shooter you don't even know
his name
should then maybe maybe illuminate that
there's a bias in in today's media that
isn't giving you the full story
and if you don't believe me on anything
you can go watch my interview with
stephen williford and you can go
google the suddenly spring shooting and
stephen williford
it was an unbelievably deadly shooting
and he stopped it with an ar-15 mean
i still go back to my initial thing like
more guns equals more deaths by gun
like you can't tell me that's incorrect
it is incorrect how
i just i just i mean like no i mean i
get it more lives are saved by firearms
more lives are saved by defensive uses
of firearms and there is no statistical
data to suggest you know you started
with
well you started with let's just get rid
of the second amendment i mean maybe
let's get into automatics okay then
maybe semi-automatic so again
either way and i think we found here is
no matter any way you slice it
for you to change you have to
do away with the second amendment and
ban guns it's not about automatic it's
not about a bump stock
semi-automatic now it's all guns people
either have the right to protect
themselves
or they don't and there is no data to
say that stripping people have the right
to self-protection
would make us safer as a matter of fact
there is some data to
suggest otherwise new york chicago
places with california lots of places
very strict gun laws that's the most
violent
gun crime in the in the country okay
i understand i guess it makes it look
like i'm saying that
guns don't protect people guns are this
and that and like they're all they bring
is harm but i'm saying that
i still believe until i look at the
statistics that you're talking about
i still like fully believe that sure
more access to guns is in it lead to
more
psychotic people getting you know
through the system that we currently
have
i mean at least you would have to agree
that we need some type of change
with regards to regulation you can't
tell me we're fine and we're doing okay
and like i certainly do away with some
things for example i would do away with
uh um 30-day waiting periods for
firearms oh yeah
i'll do away with that um yeah you know
i would i would do away without with
people not being able to purchase
suppressors for hunting
i believe more safety so you just think
we shouldn't limit the type of audience
that gets access to guns no we already
do
we already don't think we don't need any
more of a limitation like okay so
let me ask what what ways or what you
know what
avenues can we take to ensure that
things like las vegas won't happen again
never ensure that things like las vegas
or at least that bad all you can do
here's the thing
then we talked about this on the program
not long ago
human beings commit horrible acts of
evil okay you can never stop them from
doing that
you ban your ban guns in australia
violent crime is the same in the uk
violent crime has gone up
people find a way look at uh we're
actually okay so i mean and you more
than
shootings in france look at nice look at
what's what's happening look at the
terrorists
that's the most can't stop it does does
uk have more gun deaths
than we do i'm pretty sure they don't
they have more violent crime now here
here's something else that's also
important comparing violent crime
statistics across countries is very
difficult because
they have different standards for
violent crime if you look at the united
states
uh of places with the strictest gun laws
have some of the worst
gun crime now uh as far as i don't i'm
not so concerned with
just gun crime i'm concerned with
violent crime okay violent crime
there is a statistical correlation
between violent crime increasing
and populous as being unarmed being
stripped of the ability to protect
themselves
you even look at states states where
people carry firearms or people are more
likely to carry arms freely
they are less likely to be targeted less
likely to be attacked there is often
lower violent crimes there are plenty of
statistical correlations there no one is
saying that we are perfect but i think
human evil i think we both acknowledge
evil is part of the ammunition you have
some evil in you so do i people have
evil in them people have good in them i
believe all people have
all of the above so people will commit
people who get overrun with evil they
will commit acts of evil it comes down
to
what's the best way to prevent that
either you believe
in disarming all good people and also
doing away with the constitution and the
rights that
afford us everything else such as the
ability to peaceably assemble
and speak freely or uh you believe that
allowing good people
to protect themselves i don't know the
solution okay
i don't know i guess we'll agree to
disagree to some extent i understand i'm
glad
i'm glad i'm glad you educated me a
little bit on like the the positive side
of guns
but i still feel like the fact that
there's you know 17 18 year old
kids that got killed it's terrible i
mean i feel like
something that's terrible but what about
the millions i mean why don't you get
you know the nra
or millions of mothers who protect their
children at home
when dad's gone and someone breaks in or
the women who protect themselves from
being raped
right you're talking about 500 000 to
over 3 million so you can't just look
would we you can't legislate emotionally
do you feel
less uh empathetic to that woman do you
feel less empathetic to the child who
was protected by a firearm
i don't think so and just as i don't
feel less sympathetic to those lives
lost yeah
so let me ask you this before we go if
you were able to uh
research these things and if the facts
that i presented
bore out and you said okay that checks
out would that
perhaps uh change or educate your
opinion on firearms in the second
amendment a little differently
not completely probably but to an extent
possibly yeah to an extent
all right sure let me let me let's this
is actually probably there's a whole lot
no we don't do this right now
okay yeah but uh so you're ready
okay all right sorry here um
okay here if you want to write this down
here let me let me do this
uh write down if you write down these
notes sorry everyone i'm actually giving
just real quick we'll continue i'm
giving him some notes
on stats to research on his own because
he's actually he's really
open and and hunger for knowledge and i
appreciate that so i'll take some time
with him
google cdc
lives saved guns
cdc or you can google how many guns
saved
per year yes um
austria you can google australian
buyback
[Music]
actual effect or australian buyback
so violent crime so let me ask you why
are there articles that
are suggesting that uh well you know
what it's exponentially decreased
does someone have my phone here let me
show you something really quickly
because
this even happens with me by the way i
do this professionally okay
um and like i said someone who works in
the media and someone who was on
mainstream media for a
long time fox news cnn did it for a long
time it's not always very honest
uh i even get caught in the sense that
uh
mass shootings i knew these numbers were
wrong okay
so this is something that's been going
around it's been retweeted by people at
cnn
this has been retweeted and posted tens
of thousands of times right
gun massacres fell during the assault
weapons ban
okay okay but here's the thing
they're using gun map i was going that
doesn't make sense because i've looked
at this number at least 50 times i've
used it and sourced it
what they did was they took six plus
deaths okay
the standard used is actually four plus
so we've been used for a long time it
changes its discus completely those were
the standards that originally set so you
have to look at the source
it comes from lewis claravis now i can
show you
uh what it is from and then i do have to
let other people come in here yeah
but this is what is actually used
as a government standard standard for
mass shootings
as a matter of fact looks like it went
up now here's the thing i'm being fair
if you look at that right i don't think
that the assault weapons ban necessarily
increased gun crime because there's a
statistical it was going up regardless
and now it's been going down a little
bit
so i'm not going so far the other way
and said look the assault weapons ban
increased gun crime i think that's a
more balanced point of view
um but it certainly didn't decrease it
that's ewing
using the legal standards anyone can
create a statistic and then they just
say well hold on a second
i'm going to include six plus well why
don't you include four plus that's
what's been used to compare across
different countries those are the
studies that have been used
so often people will tweak that data to
change the number
little tricks like that of course that's
the assault rifle ban
that your assault weapons weapons was 94
to 2004
and the definition of a massacre is four
plus it was four plus
yeah then why did six plus decrease or
is that just like a
well hi then then you have to get into
again you look at the numbers how many
more uh
the reason they included four plus was
because there's a lot between four and
six
do we care less about those lives is
that not considered a massacre so that's
no i'm not saying that you do but my
point is that people
are dishonest and tweak the data all the
time and so that's why i think it's
important i mean
overall i mean it's not just that like
you know yeah but the undeniable fact is
violent crime you have to look at
violent crime not just gun crime overall
violent crime
and you have to look at how many lives
are saved um and then i would also
recommend that you purchase a firearm
just even if you return it go through
the process
i think you'll change your point of view
even more i think you'll realize it's
significantly more difficult than you
think
um i know my opinion changed i'm
canadian okay uh dual citizen was raised
in montreal when i first purchased a
fire i mean i was told it's easier than
buying a it's easier than buying a pack
of cigarettes
it's not true so if you can it's pretty
easy it's pretty easy compared to
it's not that easy other countries it's
much easier well compared to other
countries that don't allow it on
firearms period of course
uh but in canada we're sitting we
invented the mass shooting in canada
we had three at schools just in my
hometown of montreal anyways
right
[Music]
would you mind scooching in a little bit
just so i just otherwise it's gonna i'm
gonna throw out my shoulder
i got you so let me um
is that a bird i don't it's pretty loud
okay
let me reassert my position just to make
sure there's no miscommunication here
i am an avid supporter of the second
amendment and firearm ownership i come
from a country where that's
not a legally recognized right like
canada i'm open to new ideas and having
my mind changed
okay well um i believe that you have
your right to own a gun like that's not
a problem now i just think that
the ease of accessibility of having a
gun
is the problem and like this culture
that we have surrounding
um owning a gun is like a bit
problematic
and i mean that's my position i think
you have a right to own a gun
okay but not military-grade uh
like things that cause mass shootings
okay
how would you define military grade
assault rifles what's an assault rifle
so like uh ak-47 okay
now why would you differentiate between
say an ak-47
and a ruger mini 31. like pistols
no that's also it's a common hunting
rifle right
i'm not sure what you're asking but i
guess i'm asking because you're the one
who's proposing i assume a ban
on military standard you just use a term
assault rifle right
we don't need to have them like among
citizens i suppose people who have
military training
could have those because they're under
jurisdiction they've been trained
they've had background checks
et cetera but regular citizens such as a
19 year old boy it doesn't make sense
that he had that gun legally
sorry couple things you do have to go
through a background check to legally
purchase a firearm
perhaps it's not exclusive to the
military and um again i think it's
important for you to define
uh what military spec would be so you
mean things like ar15
yes i've forgotten the name sorry i
apologize
um uh an ar-15 is not a military right
okay
they use m16s um an ar-15 is not an
automatic weapon
so i think it's important when people
are proposing
gun control legislation to it's
important for me to understand what it
is that you're proposing
right so when you say x guns shouldn't
be in the hands of
citizens um i i would really like to
just so i'm not misrepresenting your
point of view
and and so i can know whether i
appropriately agree or not
what kind of firearm specifically would
you
uh remove from
law-abiding citizens or bar them from
in in-house so ar-15 right what kind of
gun is that
an ar-15 is a is a rifle right so i
would believe this is an automatic rifle
right semi-automatics
would be something that don't need to be
in the hands of citizens
okay so so no handguns
i mean the thing is that like handguns
and pistols have different
like caliber compared to semi-automatics
or
automatic guns and semi-automatics the
thing that that kid used
like it was much more of a severe type
than
say just a handgun no
no virginia tech was just committed with
handguns um
let me ask you are you aware of what the
differentiation is between automatic and
semi-automatic
no by the way i'm not trying to be a
smart smart assist at all but a lot of
people have sat down and said this
they don't know and that's honestly it's
because of
the disservice from the media and
deliberately conflating them
so a fully automatic weapon machine gun
would be you know
pull the trigger it keeps firing until
the magazine is empty
a semi-automatic would include all
pistols
um it's pull the trigger once a bullet
comes out
right right that's most hunting rifles
so that's why i say you know the ar-15
by the way use the caliber 223
which is really a glorified varmint
caliber
it's actually not the most powerful
caliber out there it's not even close
most hunting rifles that people use to
take down deer are actually
significantly more powerful as well as
being semi-automatic
okay many well
the vast majority of mass shootings are
carried out not using
uh rifles at all just using
run-of-the-mill handguns which
happen to be semi-automatic so um
does any of that i guess change your
point of view because you were under the
presumption that these were military
style
rifles and semi-automatics knowing that
you would effectively be removing
the only way you could do it is saying
okay a ban ban on all firearms
or what about a ban on certain firearms
rather than all
okay well that comes back to how do you
determine which firearms let me do this
i guess first because then we can get
into
it seems to me that um like you said
you're you don't know a whole lot about
firearms i'm not an expert necessarily
by any means
i was raising canada how much of an
expert can i be on firearms but i've
learned quite a bit in becoming a
responsible firearm owner
what do you believe the second amendment
is i think it's a right to defend
ourselves
okay right uh self-defense um
in the case of uh you know in the case
of a need of self-defense right
but mass shootings those aren't
self-defense
well no but that's that's a crime right
right i'm saying but before we get into
that that's a crime and we both agree
listen
no none of us no one here is advocating
for mass shootings i want to make sure
we agree on that
and i appreciate you sitting down and
keeping it civil we've had people come
by and scream and knock the camera so
i want to make sure you understand i am
very anti
criminal behavior thank you um but you
said the second amendment is for
defense i think we need to fundamentally
uh find out where we agreed first before
then we determine where we disagree
okay so the second amendment you believe
is is for defense but
how so defense against what attackers
um i believe i was i was talking to some
people out there and they said that like
in case the government goes against you
you can use um guns as a like
as a self-defense as well and was that
the first time you heard that concept
so you you'd never heard before about
the second amendment being a safeguard
against a tyrannical government
yeah okay that's why it was written
right uh that's that's that's the whole
purpose for it so
um with that context you have to
understand at that point they were
basically
uh ensuring just like the first
amendment your freedom of speech
remember you can run off right now and
say i hate him he was mean he's terrible
and you have the right to say it i would
prefer that you didn't
but the constitution says you have that
right the constitution also ensured that
the
citizens had the right to arm themselves
um by the way the same kind of armaments
that
the military had at that point um that's
what it was for
it was for protection against both
internal and external threats
government and of course to protect your
your farm your
family your property that's why it
exists
so that's what the second amendment
ensures okay um
i guess since that was the first time
you've you've heard that but uh
can we i guess agree on that as a
starting off point i suppose i think my
only issue with it
is that there's like a very a very like
it's a culture like defense of guns and
having guns is a very american culture
like why isn't this a problem in say
australia
where they had enacted a gun ban
a ban on assault rifles i believe and
then they
administered a buy-back program where
over 650 000
guns were bought back and their homicide
rates and suicide rates by gun violence
dropped significantly
a couple of things i'd like to unpack
there uh two things said why do we have
this culture in the united states
right i'll acknowledge for example where
i'm from in canada it's different than
the united states
so why is there a gun culture in the
united states
um because you have other societies
who kneeled for royalty
who didn't fight off a trinical
government we left and in order to make
sure that you're free
to practice your religion in order to
make sure that you're free
to speak by the way that's also not a
right in australia or canada freedom of
speech doesn't exist
anywhere else outside of the united
states not to its full capacity a lot of
people don't realize that
they go hand in hand we were the country
who fled the world's greatest superpower
one century
only to become the world's greatest
superpower the next century that's
never happened to that degree and that's
because we're a country founded
on the idea of private citizens being
able to own
firearms we fought off a tyrannical
government we didn't submit to them
so that will change the culture just as
you see a different culture in japan
versus germany right there are cultural
differences
when you're a culture born through
violence and i would say virtuous
violence
um i mean i would say it certainly was
virtuous violence
to fight a war to end slavery when we
agree you can
commit acts of violence that are morally
virtuous and you can commit acts of
peace that are morally reprehensible you
can peacefully sign a warrant
for millions of people to die and that
has happened so that is why
there's a fundamental mistrust of
government we fought off a government
and we wanted to ensure
that we would be able to do that in the
future because george washington
um actually george mason said who is the
militia which in the second amendment
said why it's it's the whole people
george washington fought off militias
you know there are all kinds of warring
militias in this country
the easiest thing he could have done
would have been all right fan guns no
more malicious
george washington didn't you know why
because he said i need them to keep us
in chat
our founding fathers understood since
they just fled and fought off tyranny
that it can happen within one generation
it can happen within
less than a decade so that's why it's
ingrained into our culture it's a
different culture
um you may not agree with it but that's
what the second amendment exists
does that answer maybe your question as
to why it's culturally different
right but i believe maybe the culture
was different back then like the context
is different now okay well let's let's
get to that because i wanted to get to
your second if you mentioned
australia uh so you mentioned a buyback
buyback program it was a mandatory
buyback yeah so it's a gun ban
um it's interesting to me then you said
well and then gun suicides
and gun crime went down her guns bites
by gun related suicides and gun related
uh homicides okay but they didn't
completely ban guns because they did
um i think if i'm not mistaken they did
enact
a new permit system right but it's a
mandatory buyback right you could say
it's
like if i put a ban on all epiletted
black coats right now and it's a
mandatory buyback where you have to turn
that in
or i'm going to send government men with
guns by the way ironically
to your house to take your jacket that's
a ban right right
you don't have a choice the matter then
you can say afterward well we're going
to make you get this tax stamp and we're
going to make you go through this
process and you can get your
your pretty black jacket back you
wouldn't say
oh okay that's that's that's a real
respect for my rights there mr
government i appreciate it
it's pretty pretty rough so it was a
mandatory buyback then you mentioned
that there was a decrease
in uh gun homicides and suicides first
off there's conflicting data there that
it didn't affect you
at all but there's certainly no
conflicting data that did not affect
violent crime
so uh the question becomes if someone
kills himself with a gun or someone
kills himself with a knife
you're 19 times for example more likely
to be knifed
my concern is with violent crime it's
not necessarily
a gun and it shows you that it doesn't
matter what you do with guns
violent crime remains unchanged right
now
what does change for example in the
united states is that there are far more
defensive uses of firearms
that save far far more lives than they
take so
the question becomes i think because
you're you're empathetic um
you're kind of i i don't say this i
don't want to be air game i think you're
learning
some historical context for the second
amendment hopefully and i would
encourage you to go read it don't take
my word yeah no seriously like levar
burton don't take my word for it
don't you hate it when he does that and
reading rainbow and then some
six-year-old that's like i'm supposed to
take a six-year-old's recommendation
so don't take my word for it so then
that now it comes back to the issue if
it didn't necessarily work
um understanding why we have a second
amendment now
are you still comfortable with stripping
people of their rights to protect
themselves
i don't think that's the issue with like
i think
i guess like yeah talking to you it
boils down to like this really intense
culture around
guns and having them and like the
context has changed now so we're not as
afraid of our government turning on us
anymore as you as we were more afraid of
mass shootings
and people turning on each other i see i
think that's very
that's very misguided why you're more
afraid of a mass
shooting than um government overreach
yes i suppose so you mean by government
overreaches and government takes over
infringing upon your rights yeah
tyrannical government um
i think how old are you if you don't
mind me oh really okay 18. well there
you go you're a very sharp
young lady at 18. um very well spoken uh
you just haven't lived through it it
doesn't take a lot
i mean you understand that can happen
very quickly it's still happening across
the world right now right
tyrannical governments i mean you can
see how quickly a government can change
look at turkey
right right look at iran in the 70s and
iran today
i mean rights are removed like that like
clockwork you see it with australia a
gun buyback a mandatory gun by that
these people were obeying the law one
second
and then were fugitives from the law the
next because someone decides to change
the law
this happens all the time in the realm
of human history uh
major global conflicts it's not that
long ago
what i mean and the only way we're the
only country to say hey we recognize the
human condition
we recognize that human beings are
inherently capable of evil and corrupt
but being corrupted so let's safeguard
against that and make sure that every
individual has the right to protect
themselves because
that's the fundamental worldview right
right
do you believe that good people have the
right to protect themselves against bad
people whether that's government or
a gang member well that's not
too hard to think about to be honest
like i think that argument that um the
only thing that
um stops the bad guy with the gun is a
good guy with a gun i think that's a
little bit
shaky to think about just because um
that doesn't make much sense to me you
can't always uh
i don't know i just don't i think that
argument isn't as valid as it could be i
had i had some stats in my head
okay sorry these cameras do that to you
um okay
let me ask you this if i were able to
provide you with irrefutable evidence
that that is true
as well as anecdotal evidence would you
consider changing your opinion
i suppose but i would have to depend it
would depend on the source okay
all right let me let me give you the
information in the source and i would
encourage you to google it afterwards
um how many guns do you believe in the
united states sorry how many lives do
you believe are taken by guns in the
united states each year you're gonna say
three thousand three hundred thousand
aren't you
no no no how many lies no no no no
that's that's way too high
really yeah wait okay taken
if you take away suicide it's in
anywhere from twelve thousand to sixteen
thousand
depending which source you use now how
many uh
lives how many people are saved each
year in the united states through
defensive uses of firearms
i'm not sure are you gonna yeah
would you repeat your question please
how many defensive uses of firearms
would you say occur in the united states
meaning live saved people safe
protected through legal defensive use of
firearms each year so we've just
established about
you know 12 to 16 000 excluding suicide
lives are taken oh okay and how many are
saved
i'm not sure minimum 500 000
really likely over 3 million each year
according to the cdc
okay so i'd say that's a legitimate
source right it's not cnn this is a cdc
uh a national safety council so you're
talking exponentially higher numbers of
people whose lives are saved
for defensive use of firearms than lives
are ever taken
but that still negates the idea that
that people are still able to go out
and commit mass shootings uh which
i think under the definition mass
shooting includes uh four people or more
that are killed by
the gun that's correct yeah right i
imagine i appreciate that you that
because now they've tried to tweak the
numbers and say it's six or more
to make it seem as though the assault
weapons ban worked when it didn't the
number has always been four or more so i
appreciate that you use that
um yeah but again it's such an outlier
such an outlier mass shooting
as far as the statistical likelihood of
death in the united states or even when
it comes to gun crime
uh when you remove suicides it's very
very low and then when you remove gang
on gang violence it's even lower
the statistical likelihood of you being
shot is
unbelievably low and it is much lower
if you have a firearm yourself that you
can use defensively okay so then
what if we brought the argument that
about this uh
this kid that had a closet full of guns
and was able to go into a school
and shoot a bunch of people why is it
that kid has guns
okay um well first off just there was
like 39
uh warnings issued on this kid 39
incidents reported two reported to the
fbi they think he blew away like a
chicken with a hand guy
this kid was not supposed to legally
yeah yeah i know that's like
if you're if your neighbor's killing
frogs you might want to make a phone
call um
that is people failing to do their job
legally
can't own a firearm that's why you've
never purchased a firearm i would assume
right
i would encourage you to do so and
listen go to a fight go to a firing
range learn how to shoot again at the
very least if you ever run into a
situation where you're near a firearm or
have to use it
so you have proper safety training i
encourage everyone to do that
and if you go purchase a firearm you'll
see the background check that has
already taken place you'll see that you
can't purchase a firearm if you're a
felon
you'll see you can't purchase it if you
even have committed violent misdemeanors
or domestic abuse
or if you've been uh ruled mentally
defective you go through this background
check
i've had to go through it every single
time i purchase a firearm are you sure
that's the same in all different states
yes this is a federal background check
now if we're talking about some
uh for example these fbi tips or in the
case of a military tribunal where
someone just wasn't reported
that is the failure of someone to do
their job that doesn't require new
legislation that requires people
obeying legislation and then we get into
the issue of listen criminals break the
law
and sometimes people fail to do their
job and guess what people fail to do
their job in these instances
we're in government so again we're
talking about the gross and competency
of government and the solution is to put
more power in the hands of the
government by disarming
private citizens i just think it's a
fundamentally flawed premise
um one final thing i find interesting so
that's the empirical the evidence far
more live saved
than taken i would encourage you to go
research it okay
um let me ask you this if you go and
search that and you find that that bears
out
from the cdc would that change your
opinion on
the second amendment i'm still not sure
it's a very murky
issue to be honest well you started off
pretty confident now you're not sure so
well i think you're gonna change my mind
it sounds like we're fighting we're
coming
like this a little coming closer i
suppose i think that it's i still stand
that you still can have a right to a gun
but it does not need to be nearly as
accessible as it is currently
i i still haven't heard any any
different proposal outside of a gun ban
because
you said that but then you bring up
australia to the gun ban and then
you know the second amendment so i would
encourage you to look at those sources
let's assume those are true
i would like to think a sharp 18 year
old lady such as yourself would look at
that and
that overwhelming statistical evidence
and say okay
this needs to play a part in my decision
um but obviously you'll make your own
decisions
and then we go to the anecdotal you talk
about how this idea of a good guy with a
gun stopping with a bad guy with a gun i
think is just you know
you think is incorrect so obviously you
mentioned the florida shooting
do you remember the sutherland springs
shooting
you know what was this one it's not this
is not i'm amazed it happened here in
texas
it was more deadly than florida you know
the church was shut up
the church was shut up and someone
springs outside of san antonio texas
this just happened a couple only a few
months ago yeah deadlier shooting
oh there's um no no no no no there
haven't been so many happening and this
was one of the biggest
uh does the name stephen williford mean
anything to you
okay um
i'm trying to think of how to frame this
year i don't want to be contentious at
all but i think let me put it this way i
think it is a tremendous disservice that
has been
committed against you from the media and
probably this educational establishment
for you to be this uninformed on some of
these pivotal issues the southern spring
is more deadly with a church so it's
shot up okay in texas
not that far from here and stephen
williford
you don't know him because he wasn't on
the news wasn't the story i'm sure
you've probably seen the high school
students right
from florida going around making the
rounds well steven williford is the man
who stopped the shooter
he stopped the shooter with an ar-15 he
was an nra certified instructor
okay no town hall we didn't talk about
it
more deadly shooting happened in your
backyard
you don't even know about it does that
concern you
because that was a good guy with a gun
stopping a bad guy with a gun
but then that's just one incident
happens all no then that's why i'm
combining
that with the statistical evidence that
there are far more lives as i talked
about from the cdc so the evidence the
preponderance of evidence points to
far more life saved than taken and i'm
just trying to give you an anecdotal
example
of a more deadly shooting that occurred
recently in a place that's closer to you
the media didn't cover
but the point is that would be uh
concerning to me
if this is the first time you're
learning that the second amendment is to
uh protect yourself against a trinical
government i think that's pretty pivotal
i'm i'm kind of surprised i didn't
taught in american history class i was i
was canadian i learned canadian history
so i felt
it's incredibly boring it's like we said
all right give and you know now we have
the queen on our money
um but they don't teach the second
amendment in american history in schools
i find that concerning
i find it concerning that people think
we're in a worse place with guns than
ever that
um that we have more gun crime than ever
um i find a concern that
young you're very clearly a very smart
girl and i don't say that to uh to
to patronize you um but i find a concern
that someone is articulate as
smart as you isn't aware of how many
lives are saved
through use of firearms why we have the
right to firearms
and then in particular a news story that
the media
really should go gaga over that occurred
in your home state where you are
studying
where a man saved lives with a firearm
but isn't it i'm so sorry no no i was
just saying that's very i find that very
does that not i know it is quite
concerning but isn't it more concerning
that
um i was doing research on this last
night but um because i just
yeah um according to i think the united
united nations and the human development
index that um
in the united states we were 22.9 times
more
have 22.9 more homicides per million
people than say germany or switzerland
which was like
7.7 and like i think nine for both of
those
so isn't that more alarming as well well
i think you're referring to gun homicide
right yeah
uh because violence related gun-related
homicides yeah i see i think what's
important to compare
first off one thing i do have to say and
i'll go along with that
just for the sake of us having this
discussion violent crime rates are
difficult to compare across countries
because there are different standards
kind of like infant mortality rates
right people have different standards
for what can
you know what actually um is considered
an infant um
but violent crime is actually higher and
has seen a worse trend
in places like the uk than in the united
states and in sweden particularly
uh and in germany things like rape
have been increasing well they've
actually been going down in the united
states these are very alarming
uh crimes now if you're just talking
about gun crime
okay but you're 19 times more likely to
be stabbed than shot again these the
numbers are so so minimal but the media
focuses on it
uh i think it's more important to focus
on the overall
crime trends and violent crime not the
tool of the crime because if you're
going to attribute
all of these issues to an inanimate
object and ignore the totality of
evidence
i think you're looking in the wrong
place okay i understand that
and also something else i mean keep in
mind that um
you know we're also the only place out
of all those places you mentioned that
has
freedom of speech or you can't be jailed
for saying something offensive
so that's amendment number one okay and
amendment number two
all right don't a firearm so it comes
down to i think your fundamental view of
human rights and then the statistical
data and realities of
of gun violence and uh and you know
where you line up on that but
it sounds to me like you're doing some
research um hopefully you continue to do
more i
i really do encourage you to fact check
me after this right
yeah no i had like a document there i
just like straight up forgot it you can
just tweet me and tell me
if you think i'm you know like hey you
were wrong you suck and i get that all
the time but
i don't think you probably i know you
seem like a very nice person um
so would that though if you go when you
do this research and everything that
i've said here let's say is
mostly true does it maybe change
your view a little bit um probably not
within this discussion
like as shortly i can't just radically
change my views no i'm not with you
discussion but if you go home and do
this research and well yeah because then
i have more context
okay but you know probably not now i'm
still no i don't i don't want to
that's also why i don't think we should
be proposing legislation right now
i don't think an emotive response a
knee-jerk response is
uh conducive towards you know
productive legislation in any capacity
or even you know productive formation of
opinions
so i don't want you to knee jerk i don't
want you to develop an opinion right now
sit let it percolate a little bit go do
some research
i would encourage you to look up the
sutherland springs shooting i would
encourage you to google cdc
lives saved firearms or cdc defensive
use firearms
and um you know see where you line up
but i appreciate you so much taking the
time thank you thank you very much
hey did you like this video of course
you did unless there's something wrong
with you
in which case you can comment below
what's your problem with this video we
want to hear from you and we promise you
100
i give you my word is my bond will
answer every single negative comment
uh for those who are normal you can
leave a thumbs up and subscribe